[Music]
I'm the one
you know as a amateur in the podcasting
game I'm always impressed by our guests
people like him today who when there's
no stories and you know you can create
Stories the day before you come on the
podcast and you fabricated where as a
former CIA agent Mike Baker comes in a
day before leaked Secret Pentagon
documents wow lift the lid on U.S spine
on Russia's war in Ukraine my kids used
to talk about his involvement in this as
well as why he's considering moving from
Boise Idaho to San Francisco Mike it's
great to have you on the podcast man I
mean I can't get to San Francisco quick
enough yeah yeah well you know what I
thought to myself we gotta have
something to talk about yeah so I called
up my buddies I said do you have
anything laying around any documents at
all uh put them out there preferably on
some place where people play Minecraft
yeah yeah and uh otherwise we're all
good so yeah I I can't claim
responsibility for that one though uh so
is that crazy or what I mean it's what
yeah it's it's both crazy and what uh
the question is
when you start to pour through the
documents yeah
it is a legitimate question is this just
a disinformation campaign right because
when you start to look at the at the
themes of the documents and who does who
does it benefit so while the jury is
still out and people are still assessing
The credibility of all of this and
whether in fact they are authentic
documents you have to leave open the
possibility that this was an FSB or a
Russian Intel operation to put this
material out there because I mean they
replayed it on one of their you know
propaganda channels and so that was a
that seemed like it was a fairly
orchestrated effort on the airport not
that they wouldn't do it if they saw the
advantage but it I'm just saying there's
a chance of that right let me let me
read the story and we'll just get right
into it man that's phenomenal and by the
way I still we got a lot of stories to
cover that's one of them we got uh uh
you know xci Chief dubs uh Putin Dead
Man Walking we'll talk about that CI
future will be defined by U.S technology
race for China director says you got
Gavin Newsom predicts what will happen
if DeSantis takes on Trump China warns
war with U.S could break out very well
before 2025 meanwhile Taiwan warns
Chinese misstep could lead to
uncontrollable world war France uh going
around talking [__] about America saying
you know Europe relies a little too much
in the U.S we'll talk about that a guy
yesterday there are many Joe's in
America this is one of I think it's the
seventh most famous Joe in the world he
announced that he may be running for
office for 2024 again for re-election I
don't know if you know about this guy
named Joe we'll talk about him Clarence
Thomas got a little bit of issues going
on with these trips that they're talking
about billionaires paid for
um
what else we got Twitter substack feud
with Matt taibi Elon Musk being accused
of censorship we'll talk maybe a little
bit of economy of what's going on with
inflation uh meet open aico Sam Altman
I'm curious to know what your thoughts
are on this doomsday conversation that's
coming up and I'm not sure if you're a
Bud Light Drinker Corona of course like
we're going to learn a little bit more
about that and if we have any time at
the end maybe we'll give you a shout out
for Dalai Lama's apology
what was that all about so what a [__]
that's fantastic yeah I wasn't I wasn't
a Bud Light Drinker until I see who's
drinking Bud Light now I'm thinking I'm
all in yeah
contrarian
right everybody's boycotting Bud Light
you know wobbling down yeah so so if
that's the case let's just start off
with that story so why don't we do that
so Bud Light silent on social media
after Dylan Mulvaney's uh uh controversy
another story comes out talking about
Bud Light suffers bloodbath has a long
time and loyal consumers revolt against
transgender campaign
uh let me read this story Bud Light has
fixed backlash uh uh the top selling
beer brand in the US has suffered a
nationwide backlash from consumers after
higher transgender Tick Tock star
Delaware as its new uh spokesperson
according to Bar owners and beer
industry experts around the country Jeff
fitter owner of case and bucks a
restaurant and sports bar in Barnhart
Missouri set in Bud Lights effort to be
inclusive they excluded almost everybody
else including their traditional
audience sales of Anheuser-Busch bottled
products have reportedly dropped 30
percent that is insane over the week
while drought beer plummeted 50
according to Bar owners 80 percent of
Bud Light drinkers ordered something
else this week at Braintree Brewhouse in
Massachusetts a sprawling sports bar
just outside of Boston one pup in Hell's
Kitchen a New York City neighborhood's
known for its large and vocal gay
community reported that Bud Light
traffic sales dropped 58 slots in the
gay community wild Bud Light bottle
sales were down 70 so what do you think
about this whole thing that's going on
with Bud Light yes my favorite part of
this story is first of all I don't give
a [__] what Dylan Mulvaney does right it
doesn't matter I I everybody just do
your own thing and and stay out of my
wheelhouse but uh the best part of the
story is I did watch the VP of marketing
uh for for Bud Light she came on and she
said look uh she felt like the brand
needed to be more inclusive and they
needed to get away from their frat beer
uh image right because those son of a
[__] don't drink beer no and so uh
she said she quoted she actually said
female representation is a personal
passion point of mine right so what does
she do she goes out and gets a guy with
a penis you know and says hey I want you
to promote my beer right well horrible
yeah I mean it's it's just it's bizarre
right but again I go back to the same
thing I guess at the end of the day I I
don't mind pointing out the stupidity of
that yeah but I honestly on the other
side of the coin I don't give a [__]
what people do yeah we're also you know
worked up over although I will say this
and I asked the other day I asked
someone who's very smart I said and I
was genuinely confused I said is a
transgender woman
is that a a dude who uh identifies as a
woman or is a transgender man I I
couldn't figure out which is which yeah
I think I think if it's you're a
transgender male you want to be a female
correct like you you identify a woman
nobody knows
no one back to it
a case of uh it won't go broke or
whatever though that thing is and that
you were talking about marketing during
the Giuliani thing what a horrible
decision like have you ever ever like
this is the worst demographic to go over
have you ever been around a bunch of gay
guys and like hey guys let's just
Mojitos and he's like no you know what
I'm just gonna do a kickstand of a Bud
Light nobody's Dr No gig I've never seen
a gay guy holding a can be a good point
by the way this is the girl he was
talking about this is the VP of
marketing you have to listen to what she
says watch this series yeah go ahead
I had a really clear job to do when I
took over Bud Light it was this brand is
in Decline it's been in Decline for a
really long time and if we do not
attract young drinkers to come and drink
this brand there will be no future for
Bud Light so I had this super clear
mandate it's like we need to evolve
this incredibly iconic brand and this is
that right of course there's a belief in
okay what is what does evolve and
elevate mean it means inclusivity it
means Shifting the tone it means having
a campaign that's truly inclusive and
feels like you're celebrating
but watch what she said she says it's
sort of the heart of evolution you've
got to see people who reflect you in the
work and we have this hangover I mean
Bud Light had been kind of a brand of
Friday kind of out of touch humor
I had another approach if you can pause
this here's what's crazy can you Google
the profile of a Beer Drinker by the way
her kid those panties in the back
horrible that kid's not going to be hey
she did those things
that was 100 her mind yeah when you do
the profile of a beer drink you know
what you realize eighty percent of Beer
Drinker or men yeah 100 20 are women
this is kind of like you know working
for Trojan condoms yeah and you're the
VP of marketing and you say well we're
not targeting six-year-olds you know we
we have to start targeting all the
audiences we're not being inclusive
we're targeting women
but the whole the stupidity the fact
that the way she sells it yeah how she's
thinking adult transgender Community you
know when you go online you type in what
the transgender population is do you
know how many transgender people live in
America well the number says one and a
half million right but what they're
saying one and a half million has
identify as transgender it's not really
one and a half million right it's a lot
of gen Z's that are confused the
question becomes how many transgenders
in America are over 21 years old okay do
you know how small of an audience that
is and you're trying to Target that
audience and you go away from your beer
drinkers and now you lose 30 in a week
four billion dollars she's not she's not
gonna be working there but like that
decision should cost her her job but you
know it'd be funny though the
commercials Mike I I like the hell with
the Dylan Mulvaney commercial I want to
see a commercial like a bunch of gay
trans whatever just drinking a mimosa
and they're like hey Timmy you want one
he's like [__] slams it out and then
chugs a beer that's the commercial that
they're gonna have to start making
commercials for now well yeah I disagree
with I think she's probably gonna get a
promotion because we're all talking
about Bud Light right now I know the
sales are going down but she she was put
there for a particular reason right and
this is her job her job is to do this so
she has she has actually done her
whatever you know kpis or key
performance indicators yeah
um you know that's what she was put in
place to do that's the the beauty of I
guess from her position is she probably
really isn't being you know judged based
on the increase in sales she's just got
this narrow swim Lane that she has to
stay in which is are you being inclusive
are you are you performing this mandate
that we brought you in for and she's
probably got some additional attack on
there which is VP marketing and
inclusivity or something along those
lines I'll tell you what I'm I'm so glad
we actually played that video from the
VP of marketing because if there's
somebody that we can kind of point a
finger to and say all right that's the
person because picture this we do this
all the time we have meetings we say all
right guys the what's on the agenda we
have a marketing issue we got a Content
issue we got to figure this thing out so
you sit down in the boardroom 10 of us
and we say all right guys we have a
problem bud light's been declining in
sales how do we increase sales
and then one person says we got to go
trans bro we gotta go right to the trans
Market not getting Innovative your next
Innovative campaign not like okay cool
identifying who's actually drinking our
product it's going to the woke inclusive
ESG bottom line which go woke go broke
is a real thing and then here's another
point you talk about this this whole
concept of being inclusive when you're
being inclusive to the point of just
sort of virtue signaling just the point
of your being exclusive you know here
excluding your whole [__] base of
people yeah that basically got you to
this point so it's so ridiculous to me
like Mike said I don't have a problem
with Dylan movie I don't give two shits
do your thing buddy but when you start
trying to indoctrinate the rest of us to
be like hey think this way yeah right
now this isn't the first time that we've
had a hot water Bud light's the latest a
month ago for international women's day
it was Hershey's who Hershey's her she
basically had a transgender woman as the
face of Hershey's a couple a couple
years ago do you remember the Gillette
commercials no more chocolate for you
yeah yeah
um yeah exactly Hershey's face backlash
over putting trans women on candy bar
rapper not a woman not a female can you
go lower so you can see it a chick with
a dick is the face of Hershey's you know
start oh God but then and then do you
remember a few years ago when uh
Gillette had their commercial the best a
man can get yeah do you remember that
yeah for years they built our brand on
like being man like I don't know if you
know this most women don't shave their
face you know they do stay the hell away
from me but they basically went woke
went broke and lost billions of dollars
by trying to basically Curry favor from
the metoo movement feminist agenda and
dudes who shave their face are like I'm
playing this game buddy
as a single guy Dylan Mulvaney is not at
all your type no no no no
it's cool
let's not forget who started it you know
who's responsible for all this the
Kardashians they ruined Bruce was like
you know what it was you Bruce used to
be Bruce Jenner he became Caitlyn and in
six months six months they named him
woman of the year you know what he said
though you know what he said about this
yesterday what did you hear what he said
he she she well he's not supportive of
this okay right he may he commented
yesterday and pain these are domestic
terrorists she made comments about it
she's like I'm not Caitlyn I'm not I'm
not doing this so she's against what's
going on today I mean that's Kid Rock
did by the way oh you see that video the
shooting yes yeah I I try to I try to
avoid see what Kid Rock does from day to
day but but uh before I forget because
I'm getting to that point where if I
don't say something right away I forget
uh a buddy of mine who's a comic Jimmy
Fila he he talks about Caitlyn Jenner he
says look we all forget he was the
[__] goat right he was he was he was
an incredible athlete right and so when
he did come out to your point yeah they
were all like oh my God isn't she Brave
yeah she gets the ESPN award she gets uh
she's a woman of the year Vanity Fair
whatever and then as soon as she started
talking to you to your point as soon as
Caitlyn Jenner came out and started
talking conservative they were like [__]
her yeah [__] him yeah [__] him they
changed it
what that means is that whole concept is
it's politics over America I agree it's
ideology Over America and that's what's
one of the reasons why we're
experiencing what we're experiencing
right now going off of Mike said earlier
like the decision that the VP and I kind
of agreed that that might that obviously
the internal they're like yeah good for
you like doing all this but Pat as a CEO
your company gets this backlash and you
lose four billion dollars of the
companies like uh worth what do you do
as a CEO what are you doing when that
happens but you have to realize there's
two different things yeah this would
never happen to a startup
that's being ran by a Founder yeah
companies are being ruined after a
Founder started it years ago and it's no
longer around those are the companies
that are being ruined because the
founder would sit there and say do you
even know what was the reason why we
started a company do you know who we
started it for do you know what this
product was for what the hell are you
doing who proved you doing this anyways
I want to talk to the CMO that approved
your campaign there's no way VP of
marketing can get that approved without
a CMO signing off on it or CEO saying
this ad is approved at to do what you're
doing there's no way that approval
process is going to be and if it is
guess what that tells you there's a lack
of accountability there it just costs
them a lot of money but I'll tell you
the other part here's the other part
anytime there's a mishap like this
there's opportunities for others anytime
you know the whole thing with made in
China guess what all these guys started
talking about our clothes are made in
the USA are this are made in the USA are
that are made in the USA you know how
many breweries right now are sitting
there going using this as an
advertisement the most creative one is
going to be the one that's going to get
market share the next three six twelve
24 months you're gonna see and for us
when he said she's doing her job well
what is her job if her job is to
increase because Anheuser-Busch if you
look at Anna can you Google
anheuser-busch's ESG score they have won
the lowest ESG scores in America okay I
think it was like it 13.8 percent or
eight you'll see it when it comes up
right now what's the number they have a
very very low ESG score wow there you go
19.6 which is low right Lord and
Heineken super low score uh industry
rank 18 out of 607 okay so they're not
they're not at the top of the game
they're doing bad low okay so what do
they need to do if the goal was to
increase the ESG score Bingo she won
that's your point you're right that's
what I'm saying she's she's accomplished
whatever it was that was jammed through
the boardroom that and it has to push
and they you know they hired a whole I'm
they've gotta I'm sure they've got a
whole element there a unit that that is
focused on this and I think she's you
know I think she's cemented her position
oh yeah for sure so but anyways here's
here's one data I just saw Rob I'm gonna
send this to you I want you to take a
look at this
from statista and it's it's about you
may have seen this a couple months ago I
want to say uh what's his name talked
about this uh Bill Maher talked about
this but this actually breaks down the
data Rob I'm going to send it to your
Mac Pro Book Pro and as well as your
phone so whichever one you get it pull
it up take a look at this because to me
if I'm sitting in a marketing team and
we're trying to get our product to a new
audience a new market you have to pull
up data and you have to look at
statistics and say what Market are we
not in to get into look at this data
here from statista this is not a
political party this is not a left this
is not Fox this is not CNN this is
statista 72 percent of U.S adults
identify as LGBT just 40 years ago was
less than one percent wow okay it's not
7.2 percent
and then if you go by 2014 where it was
okay yellow is Millennials gen Z's
didn't exist yet or green is uh gen X's
then he got Boomers and he got uh
seniors right traditionalists
if you go to 2017 Millennials go up 20
20 Millennials go up 20 22 Millennials
go but look at gen Z right off the bat
was 16 now 19.7 of gen Z's identify as
LGBT that's that's one in five Vinnie
one in French so now people say no one's
grooming what do you mean they're just
natural yeah yeah they're choosing yeah
on who they want to be this is their
choice no this Statistics tells a story
of what's going on yeah and there's a
reason why a lot of parents are worried
did you see a a third Congressman just
flipped from democratic party oh I
didn't see that yeah it was third rapper
three representatives in the last 30
days that flipped from Republic from
democratic to Republican party two from
Louisiana okay well there's one in
Carolina yeah one in Carolina yeah and
it just said we can't we're going to the
other side you're going to see a lot
more of these happening because there
are Democrats regrets that were Kennedy
Democrats that are sitting there just
saying I don't know man I just can't be
going with this anymore this kind of
stuff is starting to become very very
weird right now yeah well I just want to
validate exactly what you're saying with
that I mean Bill Maher did that about
can you show that the North Carolina
person that flipped so okay right there
North Carolina yeah and two more from
Louisiana flipped as well and go back to
that statista if you don't mind but
here's actually something that I think
that we we should remember I actually
just saw this on Fox News I sent you
this story something that gen Z does
that no other generation does is
watch Tick Tock of all day if you don't
think that China who owns bite dance or
the CCP owns by tents is basically
promoting their algorithm to promote
this type of information to gen Z you'd
be foolish and you'd be naive here's
actually something I saw on Fox News
recently where this trans former trans
influencer basically saying hey I was
that guy I'm that dude like whatever I
drink the Kool-Aid or the Bud Light and
I'm full on blaming uh Tick Tock for the
rise of this gender ideology because you
know the algorithm on Tick Tock
basically it's like once they suck you
in boom you're going down that rabbit
hole so if you're young if you're 16 18
20 and you're kind of just figuring it
out yeah you don't really have strong
feelings or an ideology it's crazy as
that sounds what you just said watch
what Biden just did this is a story from
the Washington examiner Biden enlists
hundreds of social media influencers for
upcoming re-election bid of course Joe
Biden is enlisting help of hundreds of
social media influencers in his
unannounced re-election bid with an
emphasis on mobilizing young voters
according to Newport influences will be
cross-platforms such as Tick Tock
Instagram and Twitter will praise
Biden's accomplishments and agenda to
their followers the influencers are not
getting paid and there are four digital
staffers devoted to working with them
who are officially employees of the
White House some of the enlisted
influencers include 20 year old Tick
Tock Creator Harry Sison Boston college
professor and Twitter users Heather Cox
Richardson and financial tick tocker
Vivian too what do you think about this
trip oh God you know who doesn't want uh
Tick Tock to be banned nationally the
Biden Administration obviously when you
read that story and you think to
yourself okay are they going to ban Tick
Tock uh probably not given that we've
got the 2024 election coming up and you
know I give the Democrats credit because
they are much better at messaging
they're much better at understanding the
Dynamics of communicating right and the
Republicans you know they couldn't
organize panic in a dupe summary right I
mean they're really they need to pay
attention to what the dams are doing
because they they are effective you can
agree or disagree with how they go about
it and frankly the other point then I'll
shut up is it is that bite dance in
China
completely different animal yeah right
there is no way in hell that 99 of the
crap on Tick Tock would ever make its
way on the bite dance they won't allow
it right and there's a reason for that
is because they look at it and go this
shit's degenerative so anyway that's no
I agree with you so I'm like what do you
think and going off Adam's Point what do
you think hey obviously biting them like
it because of the reach that it gets to
these young people but what is what is
China because I don't trust China at all
I don't give a sh every time I talk [__]
people like all your races no I'm not
racist against the Chinese I'm I hate
the Chinese government how they treat
their people do you think that China is
just trying to make our youth soft just
in case I'm just going for for
militarily if you have to attack or
whatever as long as the men are soft you
can take over or like a revolution from
yeah sure I think absolutely they look
at they look at this as a as a as a
essentially a a cold war on many
different fronts right so they're out
there hoovering up economic information
right they're Gathering all they've been
doing that for decades very aggressively
and they're busy building up their
military and they're also understanding
the impact of technology and they've
been looking at this I mean it's the
same thing that's Russian disinformation
whatever it may be it's the same thing
the Chinese just have more the regime
has more resources yeah I agree with you
I I it drives me crazy when people go
well look at you you know I choose
xenophobic yeah you know no I'm talking
look at Chinese culture history people
amazing right it's an incredible place
the regime
sucks right she has cemented himself as
president for life he is he has put his
thumb down their internal security
service is stronger than it's ever been
there's no rule of law right and and
it's all thanks to XI and his and his
cronies look they believe that they are
as close as they've ever been to the top
step of the of the ladder on the food
chain right they are and they are
convinced that they're almost there and
they're acting like it one more point
the uh you brought up uh basically what
they show on tick tock
in the United States which has already
been banned by many government officials
India I think has banned some other
companies have banned it is wildly
different of what they showed the youth
in China by the way Vinnie do you know
what they show the youth in China on
American social media apps like uh
Instagram YouTube Facebook Snapchat do
you know what they showed you in in
China yeah from art no yeah nothing
because that's not allowed in their
country okay they don't allow any of the
our American owned apps in their country
well they do they do show the Bud Light
commercials
oh that's for sure yeah yeah you know
you know why you're while you're talking
about the story came out yesterday about
AI but chaos BT chat chaos gbt I don't
know if you heard about this or not
tweets out plans to destroy Humanity
after being tasked now watch this pretty
wild right when you go down but look
what it says so you're like okay this is
probably just kind of a bunch of uh no
you know some questions are being left
unanswered and on AI bot was recently
given five horrifying tasks to destroy
Humanity which led to its attempt to
recruit other AI agents researching
nuclear weapons and sending out ominous
tweet about Humanity the bot chaos gbt
is an altered version of open AI Auto
gbt the publicly available open source
application that can process human
language can respond to tasks given by
users in a YouTube video posted on April
5th the bot was asked to complete five
goals destroy Humanity establish Global
dominance cause chaos and destructions
and again control Humanity through
manipulation and attain immorality
immortality before setting the goals the
user enabled continuous mode to which a
warning appear telling the user that the
commands could run forever or carry out
actions you would not usually authorize
and should be used at your own risk in a
final message before running chaos gbt
asked the user if they were sure they
wanted to run the commands to which they
replied why for yes Pat yesterday of
this funny that's crazy that the story
comes out yesterday I was like it's
happening with all I was like Hey Alexa
turn on Spotify and she's like you're
all gonna die I was like what I'm like
turn on Spotify it's like nothing what'd
you say it's like nothing I so I was
gonna ask you Mike are you more scared
of our adversaries teaming up like China
and Russia Saudi Arabia and Iran or are
you more fearful of the AI situation
that's every single day it's getting
crazier and crazier and these robots are
warning us what they're going to do yeah
I mean I I'm more worried about AI Ai
and how a state not aligned with our own
interests and our allies interests can
use it right so I'm not worried that
somehow China and Russia are going to
meld together as as you know some best
friend for life and and you know they're
always going to kind of come and go
based on what their own personal you
know or or nation's best interests are
but the AI thing I mean look we we had a
problem before AI with nobody bothering
to do any research right they'd re
whatever they saw on Tick Tock or on
whatever that shot them all in sure I
believe that [__] because nobody takes
the time to critically think about the
information that's thrown at them and
you know look I I I don't think I'm not
a backer of the idea that we should take
some sort of break on researching AI I
think that's the wrong approach because
in part because the Chinese regime is
not going to take a break on on
developing technology but uh I do think
we need to understand exactly how
dangerous it's going to be I want to ask
this question so as a as a guy who's in
that world and you you were you were an
agent for how long what was the uh going
on 20 years you were a CIA agent for 20
years covert operations office right so
you were a this was your job this was
not like a person's using somebody in
media to say hey we want you to kind of
help us out with some information right
no this is what you did for a living
okay and when you were in what year to
what year were you in what were the what
were the years you served
um I was in I got out uh
around 2000 or so so 1980 to 2000 give
or take yeah okay so during those years
Facebook comes out of no four okay I
think Myspace is O3 O2 I don't know the
exact year but it's around the same time
can you check to see when Myspace came
out so social media wasn't really fully
around no from 1980 to 2000. so during
that time when you guys are working on
Ops and you're worried about China or
Russia or what they're doing what were
some of those threats then that you know
they used to you know inject their
propaganda and their beliefs we've all
seen what that Russian operative what's
his name Boris you know when he says
well the disinformation and they use
this and they use that what were some of
the fears and concerns you had when you
saw how they attacked us yeah I mean
this has been going on forever it's a
great a great point that you're you're
raising the technology has made it
easier right to influence people to to
to get your ideas out there
um so if you think about
go all the way back to World War II
right before uh Hitler invaded Russia
um then they were allies right so what
was Russia busy doing they were busy
trying to influence and and Germany to
some degree as well trying to influence
U.S public opinion at the time it was
very sort of uh isolationist at the
point so the the Russian agents were
here they were influencing trade unions
they were buying journalists right to
print articles they were setting up fake
associations right that would push
isolationism so it was a it was a more
laborious process in a way those things
are still done right but the technology
has just sped the ability to do that to
influence so if you're trying to
influence the population of a small
country to overthrow it to get rid of
some despotic dictator for instance uh
in the old days it was a long-term
covert action campaign right and and
now you've just got so so many options
right and people have I think something
else that's happened is again this idea
that because every generation wants it
to be easier for their own kids right
eventually you get to diminishing
returns and by that I mean you know
naturally my father wanted it to be
easier for me his father you know wanted
to be easier for him I want it to be
easier for my kids well eventually you
get to this point
where it becomes so uh soft right you
you could you can have the [__] that
goes on around us right because we're
not worried about going out and finding
clean water and collecting food and and
you know it's it's I don't know maybe
that theory is completely off but that's
where I'm I'm going so so they would buy
let's just say journalists that's
working on New York Times or they will
buy journalists that work in at a major
paper that was one of their ways and
then hey write this or influence this
and that was their way to getting to the
people yeah you would look for you would
uh typically it would be a a sort of a
broader campaign you wouldn't say just
one right I mean and you operate on a
lot of different levels like this is
nothing new I'm not you know talking
this is Mike how would they make sure
that they wouldn't whistleblower say
anything
why how would they make sure the
journalists wouldn't come out and say I
just got approached by this and they're
paying me this much money I just want to
come out and tell here's what I've been
doing it's the same way you would go out
and say I'm gonna I'm gonna you know
recruit some asset right you have to you
have to ensure that you understand what
their motivations are right it's the
same thing right so you know that's why
you wouldn't go after somebody you know
who would be a leading journalist of
their day right because they've in in
today's world right you've got somebody
who's got you know 10 million followers
you know and so you're not going to
necessarily do that you're going to do
it a more subtle way which is what the
technology allows you to do right it
allows you to put it in there in various
ways and people watch something on Tick
Tock and their first thought is not this
is probably disinformation or I wonder
if somebody's paying for this campaign
yeah would it be easier to be a CI agent
today or during your time meaning the
tools the tools are the tools are the
tools they're always going to what the
tools are going to evolve and they're
going to change and they're going to be
here and they're going to move on is it
harder to be an agent today to catch or
is it easier to find their fingerprints
in different places and kind of work it
backwards yeah that's it's it's it's
easier today in certain ways right
you're not you're not uh walking around
in the middle of some you know [__]
uh trying to figure out where the hell
you are using the map and a compass
shooting at Azimuth you know I mean
you're just like so you're just like
looking at your phone going yo we're
right here you know we're half a click
away from the Target and in in the old
days you'd be like God I don't know
where the hell we are because I don't
want to make it sound overly simplistic
but there's some truth to that and or
you're stomping around you know
someplace looking for a phone that
actually works right because you're in
some place that's you know difficult a
challenging environment now you got to
figure out where is there a a phone I
can actually this is actually Payphone
Payphone yeah remember those days and so
but uh
in other ways it hasn't really changed
because in other ways
the key to intelligence right whether
you're talking about U.S intelligence
Community are you talking about the
Brits or anyone out there or our
adversaries the key is the human Source
right I mean the the technology has
improved in terms of your collection of
technical information right you know
we've got satellites up there floating
around right I mean there's China has
this you know program trying to capture
all the data off our satellites you know
we talk about is you know space can
become weaponized it already is okay I
didn't say that and so but at the core
of intelligence is the human right and
and that really hasn't changed that much
right identifying who's got access to
something who's possibly motivated to
talk to you and why you know that's
probably never gonna what would the
profile of people that could be uh uh
bot like and what I mean by that is when
you want to get somebody that uh uh has
given us until and is becoming a spy for
us and getting somebody from Russia
that's giving us feedback of what
they're doing what profile would you
look at to see this guy could be a good
asset for us yeah yeah I mean I would
argue that in places like China or
places like Russia it can be easier
because you've got more opportunity
right they're living in a a in a
you know it's
you've got more Avenues of attack right
in a place like the US where
you know you still have you still have
your Traders unfortunately people like
James Nicholson and edley Hansen and or
uh sorry uh Hanson and edley Howard and
and uh Alder James and all these guys so
you still have people like that but it
is a little bit easier I think to Target
people who are living under the thumb of
a regime
um because you can point out the obvious
you know to some degree but typically
ideology and you know and there's been a
lot written about all of this and and
the techniques for recruitment so I'm
not again this is not sources and
methods but
um you know typically ideology is not
the the driver right it's something else
it's something more personal it's maybe
it's something as base as money maybe
it's they don't feel like they got
enough hugs right A lot of times they
feel disrespected right and you're
saying ideology is not the number one
motivation yeah typically not become an
asset yeah yeah when you when you think
about the the biggest cats I mean and
that's although that's you know some of
the the best Russian sources we've had
over the years again not nothing new
this stuff's been out there is uh you
know they have been based on ideology
but for the most part it's something
else their kid is sick and they need
access to health care or something
whatever it may be and it could be very
pedestrian as a reason but you have to
look for those things and again I guess
the point being going back to the
original point is is the the technology
helps to speed things along sometimes
but underlying that you know you still
you need somebody you can collect all
the information you know remotely and
through intercepts that you you want but
you need somebody standing in that tent
who can then tell you what everybody
looked like when they made this decision
right or what would they actually
thinking yeah because like I wasn't I
was in the United States Air Force at a
nuclear missile base what was my first
uh my first assignment and to get my
clearance I'll never forget I go home uh
and I'm at the mall in my town and my
fifth grade mind you I'm 19 at this
point my fifth grade math teacher Mr
Bonaparte big buff but he was a football
player black guy he was like oh Shauna
I'm like hey Mr Bonaparte we have a
moment he's like what the hell are you
doing and I'm like what do you mean he's
like the somebody in the government
called me I'm not even joking and they
asked me if I thought that you as a
child would grow up to do anything to
like sabotage and do something against
the country and I'm like what he's like
yeah he's like good luck whatever the
hell you're doing he's like get I'm not
I can't make this up and I was like whoa
that's just part of the vetting process
that's for the airport that's normal
though so yeah but Mike going to my
point you're talking about technology so
like when you have have like it's easier
I I'm guessing for their like digital
profile like a Mark Zuckerberg with
Facebook that must have been the CIA and
the government's just like oh my God
people have been fighting to keep this
information now you're just giving it
because it's cool to do that helps yeah
well it does oh I mean look you know I
run a company that you know private
sector business that does intelligence
and investigations and due diligence and
the amount of information that's
available out there on the average
citizen not not just here in the US but
around the world for the most part uh
it's astonishing compared to 20 years
ago you know 30 years ago for for sure
but uh it's it you know it's again it's
a uniquely American mindset which is
it's the government I got to worry about
no it's not it's the it's the private
business or the private sector that's
been hoovering up all this information
that you've been gleefully happily
giving them let me tell you something
Mike yeah a generation ago you could
literally have a family in the next town
over and your family would not know okay
now if you look at another girl's story
on Instagram your salute CIA girlfriend
will find you in less than 24 hours
that's like speaking from experience 100
not speaking from experience I love you
babe no but it's it's so true that that
technology has sped up everything in our
lives for good and for bad yeah and I
might just really fast not to go up so a
lot of people get uh confused when it
comes to agent CIA agent which you were
to assets and my question is when it
comes to like an asset is there an
expiration date on that person like
let's say you use them on a mission are
they just on standby for future or is it
kind of like no good luck goodbye yeah
terminology always was always uh trips
people up you're right
um it's not so much agent
um you know it's officer got you don't
know why got you um asset you're right
is the the the the target not the
individual agent is typically law
enforcement for the most part
um and there is a difference yeah
there's a difference between law
enforcement recruitment of of assets or
sources an Intel Community right and
this is kind of goes across the board
it's not just I don't think it's from my
experience it's not just in the US is
that
you know you tend to from an Intel
perspective you tend to look at assets
for long term because you never know
where they're going to end up right law
enforcement for good reason sometimes
it's a you know it's a project specific
or a case-specific you know recruitment
or development of a source and then boom
you're gone right or you or you need to
burn the source because you're moving
towards you know the courts so there's
there is a big difference there
um but you know human nature being what
it is I don't know that motivations have
changed that much right I think
attention spans have shortened but I
don't think motivations have changed
that much for for people Mike are you
following this restrict act have you
heard this story about what the restrict
Act is boy you know I'd like to say I
have them because I would make me sound
smarter yeah but I don't have a clue
what you're talking about okay so this
is this is something that a lot that's
exactly what a CI agent would say yeah
yes when study and restrict act for
months you've just been outed Mike well
and so is your family next uh town oh
yeah
let me read the top Rob if you can just
write the restrict act establish it's a
risk-based process tailored to rapidly
changing technology and threat
environment by directing the Department
of Commerce to identify and mitigate
foreign threats to information and
Communications technology products and
services now the key word there says
foreign threats very soon they're going
to add an additional word called
domestic threats yeah you know where
you're in uh America you're creating
content on YouTube according to restrict
act we got to shut you down because your
content is this you're doing what you're
doing on you know Instagram or Tick Tock
or Twitter so you you know we talked
about this with Giuliani to see what his
thoughts were because for me I asked
them a question I said as much as the
RICO acted good and you were able to
catch all the bad guys that kind of also
set the tone for us to come up with the
Patriot Act and the next Act and the
next ACT which means more and more and
more of big brother or somebody you know
watching over what we're doing why
should this be something people should
be concerned about
well because look with the exception I
mean realizing where I came from but so
there is a I think a need for uh secrecy
on certain things sources and methods
and there's a reason why there's a need
to know to some degree but there's also
a very important reason why you need as
much transparency in government as
possible right
um and so I part of that is how curious
are the people that you send to
Washington represent you are they asking
the right questions you know are they or
is it basically just a self-interested
frat party or actually well that's
sexist of me to say that isn't it uh but
they would have Bud Light though they
would have fun light it's gonna be all
right that joke is Never Gonna never
gonna get old it's always always good
all right so
yeah I I think that there's
you know half the time look there's a
there is as again I'll speak to what I
know which is the uh the agency there's
a well-worn path between uh agency
headquarters and uh Capitol Hill in
Washington DC of briefers going back and
forth and back and forth and talking to
the Senate Intel committees and and
Congressional Intel committees and and
explaining to them what's going on and
then there's this game that gets played
in Washington where when something
breaks and it looks like you know the
the Intel Community was engaged in
something that people didn't know about
or oversight didn't know about it's
horseshit of course they knew about it
right they just but there's a game that
gets played where they can go out in
front of the cameras and express angst
and anger over I can't believe this is
going on I'm gonna get to the bottom of
this we're gonna start an investigation
of course no investigation ever results
in anything in Washington DC but it's an
important point which is you need to
have that communication you need to have
uh your Intel Community your law
enforcement on the particularly on
federal level talking to your
representatives and them asking
questions and trying to ensure that you
know there is to the degree that it's a
possible transparency yeah okay I want
to transition to Pentagon Stories the
only reason I'm asking is I thought you
would know more about the restrict act
because this this is a for a lot of
content creators amongst content
creators a lot of people are talking
about this because you know when when
you get to move the goal post and you
can kind of create guidelines to Target
whoever you want during any season just
because something was according to
allegedly and all these guys nowadays
that are getting allegedly and their
lives are being ruined by allegedly
instead of actually being convicted or
charged it's a very weird difficult time
we're living in so some people are
sitting there saying listen man all
these new acts are coming up we saw what
happened last time you came up with this
and it backfired on a lot of different
people here's a guy Giuliani who his
license has been suspended he he doesn't
have a way of making money right now as
a lawyer just because allegedly he was
part of something he hasn't lost it yet
he's not been this part but his license
is not there for him to practice it's
it's important to just protect those
people who are doing podcasts and shows
and they're giving their opinions and
they're giving their thoughts versus
saying it's one of the reasons why I
love what Rumble is doing we're not not
a uh uh we don't I don't even know if we
put our shows on Rumble regularly or not
we're not one that promotes rumble or
any of that but the reason why I love
what musk did I love what Spotify did I
love what Rumble did what musk did with
Twitter scared the crap out of everybody
because they were always United together
with Jack Dorsey and all of them the
moment they lost Twitter with musk they
all had to check themselves the moment
musk brought Twitter back on Facebook
and all those guys brought Trump back on
right so Spotify the moment Spotify did
in silence uh Joe Rogan they realized oh
[__] there's another place they can go
take their podcast with right so we
could take a loss even though all those
guys starts I'm gonna take my songs off
I'm never gonna sell here okay no
problem Spotify said yeah we don't care
we're going to be fine yeah Joan Baez oh
my God Joan Baez is leaving Spotify
that's right that's right hell am I
going to listen and even even Rumble you
know what Rumble is doing right now
Rumble is kind of getting YouTube to
realize there's a second option so if
you choose to really constantly do this
you know the Patriot Act concern becomes
if they target the guys that are on
those platforms how can we now control
people on Twitter even though it's owned
by Elon Musk how can we control people
on uh Rumble this is one of the reasons
why some people are concerned about
restrict act quick point I don't feel
bad because this is very new I think it
came out less than a month ago when The
Tick Tock CEO testified in front of
Congress and essentially the concern
with this restrict Act is is that
they're using you know Banning Tick Tock
as a trojan horse to say we gotta you
know we gotta get this out of here but
then it's going to be a slippery slope
to like next thing you know Instagram's
band or YouTube's banned and it's just
more government control and you know our
friend Reagan once said the most
terrifying words that you ever hear is
I'm from the government and I'm here to
help and I think that's the biggest
concern about this and then I I know
we're going to switch gears here but
also speaking of government control the
whole Central Bank digital currencies
the cbdc's things that's another concern
to coincide with this restrictor Rob can
I read this can can you zoom in a little
bit more to read this I mean you're
gonna have to work with me here because
I can't
so so yeah so as I'm going right you got
to go do that with me okay uh so this is
what restricting the emergence of
security information Communications
technology act or to restrict that okay
fine let's see what it says so this is
March 7th a month ago this bill requires
Federal actions to identify America we
just read this for interest information
communication technology ICT products
and services penalties for violations
under the bill I wonder what that is
specifically the Department of Commerce
must identify deter disrupt prevent
prohibit investigation and mitigate
transactions involving ICT
products and services in which any
foreign adversary such as China okay
they're starting it off with China but
that'll change in a minute has any
interest in that pose and undue or
unacceptable risk to the U.S national
security or safety of U.S persons
additionally Commerce must identify a
refer to the president any covered
Holdings that poses an undoor
unacceptable risk to U.S national
security or the security of safety of
U.S
uh uh keep going keep going
keep going persons if the president
determines that the holding possesses
such a risk the president May compel
divestment okay so this specifically
sounds like it is a Tick-Tock type of a
thing they're targeting right it doesn't
sound like it's a U.S company they're
targeting but everything starts off like
Second Amendment a lot of guys that are
worried about any kind of slight
regulation because then they're going to
say oh now we got this oh now let's get
this oh now let's get that oh now let's
bet oh now let's amend this oh now let's
amend that so anyways it starts like
this and it gets a little bit more into
your business well I think it does I
mean you know look it's it's sort of a
sidebar to sypheus and some of the other
you know uh regulations that are out
there about you know what companies can
come into the US and and purchase
um so I I there's a but you're right in
the sense that the government does tend
to throw a big net out there on any
issue on any concern right and then with
the assumption that well at some point
maybe we'll tidy it up and we'll we'll
restrict the parameters we'll get it a
little bit more specific but right now
we're going to throw that net out there
and see what happens so I think there's
so you're right to be concerned about
the sliding uh nature of U.S government
actions and which is again why uh you
know transparency is is you know
probably the best way because once you
get this information out there once
people understand and nobody you know
I'm a good case in point to your point I
don't feel bad not knowing about if it's
a month old honestly if it was a year
old I probably still wouldn't so you
know well I got us a big tick tocker
yourself oh you would sure do all this
stuff one last one you know the whole
foreign adversaries thing
so you brought up Rumble well Rumble we
know was I think formed in Canada yeah
so that should be a concern because
where do they label foreign
to me
Rumble is necessary for the marketplace
okay Spotify is necessary for the
marketplace okay Twitter is necessary
for the marketplace because it minimizes
bullion you can't bully when there's
alternative options Bud Light doing what
they did there's no other there's so
many different other beer companies that
the Market's like yeah you know what no
problem let's find out maybe you're
right it may be the transgender if it
takes your stock to the next level sales
goes up 60 we'll sit there and say
salute good for you I don't know where
you found the market but congratulations
but if the market drops 30 like it did
last week and they're going to cores now
watch if core says well we also have to
follow our ESG score and course is
something stupid like this and they go
grab somebody else then they're also
falling to Camp someone has to come out
who was the guy that did the commercial
was it Jeep there's a commercial like 10
years ago or five years ago where the
commercial was about here's why
America's great and it was a voice like
that yeah the reason why America is
great because we build things we're
Builders yeah and you're listening to
this you're like I am a builder this is
what we do and you're like damn I'm I
love Jeep
I think
that was a great barbasol commercial
um uh it was like a World War II setting
right and the thing the guy was you know
talking to like as if he was your your
granddad a great Granddad and he was he
was in a in a foxhole or something it
was I don't remember I I'm sure Rob
could find it
um by the way he's like the hardest
working son of a [__] he's like the
disc jockey over there
doing all the biggest strip club he's
the best there it is the top thing
like a man
can we play it though
it works if you see it it's about what
it's about like in war and that looks
like a saving by Ryan scene
but but you know what that's exactly by
the way you saw this this uh Super Bowl
there was a uh uh commercial about Jesus
did you did you see what was the hashtag
that they use
um what was the Super Bowl oh really oh
you didn't catch them
I didn't see it oh he gets us he gets it
he gets us was the hashtag so
everybody's like what is this guy
talking about he gets us who is he gets
us who is he gets us anyways it was an
ad he gets us a campaign to promote
Jesus and Christianity is running two
ads during the game as part of a
staggering 100 million dollar media
investment wow so what's cool about this
is guess what now let's see the other
side okay let's see the other side that
someone has got to Target somebody who
you know is a regular Family Guy
watching football you know likes to
compete likes to watch UFC drinks all
this stuff hey give us a commercial
there see what happens right yeah can we
relate to something like that it's going
to be interesting if they allow
competition to happen let's go into the
league Pentagon uh secret documents lift
and uh the lid on U.S spine on Russia's
war in Ukraine this is an NBC news story
and then I'll give the wsj story as well
so dozens of League defense defense
department classified documents have
been posted online revealing U.S spying
on Russia's War Machine in Ukraine and
secret assessment of Ukraine's combat
power as well as intelligence gathering
in America's allies including South
Korea and Israel highlights from the
documents include the fact that Russia's
private mercenary outfit the Wagner
group has sought to purchase weapons
from NATO's member turkey and that the
group is considering recruiting more
convict for the war in Ukraine
additionally a document marked secret
examines why Ukrainian bombs equipped
with the U.S made guidance systems known
as joint direct attack Munitions or
jdam's have failed recently South Korea
has concerns about providing artillery
shells to the U.S to replenish America's
supplies as officials worried about the
ammunition would end up in Ukraine's
military document marked secret assets
Pathways for Israel to provide lethal
Aid to Ukraine providing hypothetical
situations that might drive Israel from
its Balancing Act between Kiev and
Moscow the leadership of Israel's mossat
foreign intelligence service encourages
staff to take part in anti-government
protests that have swept Israel
according to one document what are your
thoughts on the story well first of all
anything Mark's secret it's basically
got the classification level of anything
that's on Tick Tock right so because it
to what we were talking about before the
government casting a wide net there's a
lot of over classification that goes on
right and but secret is your your lowest
level of classification and you look at
this and you think again because you
gotta it's like an investigation right
you you don't build your investigation
on on Theory right you base it on
evidence on facts right otherwise you
you're by the time you get done it's
just on Shaky Ground so when you're
doing something like this and it's a
counterintelligence issue and you're
trying to figure out you know is this a
a genuine leak if so that's a fairly
simple process you figure out who had
access to the information in today's
world a lot of people have access right
right we came out at 9 11 and one of the
things they talked about was you know
there wasn't enough sharing of
intelligence so guess what we overshare
and so in part that's a problem but
you look at this and you think okay what
are they talking about here you know
some of the documents talked about uh
Russia oh we're going to start a a
propaganda campaign in Africa no [__]
Sherlock of course they are right uh or
they're talking about the the J dams not
being you know as effective well who
does that benefit when you talk about
this so you start looking at the
information that's in these documents
and you have to keep an element of this
is on one side you have to think okay is
there a chance that this is a you know
covert action campaign by the Russians
to put this information out there
because a lot of it does you know hey
look if if we put an article in there or
a document in there about uh the South
Koreans being a little bit uh iffy on
providing shells if we talk about
Egypt's going to sell Russia you know
weapons if we talk about the UAE coming
together with an agreement with
all that [__] you know I'm not sure that
you know there's not a a possibility
here that it is a disinformation
campaign if it's not if they're
authentic documents and
quite frankly the government already
knows that right they're just not
telling us you know when John Kirby
stands up there and goes well we don't
know we don't know whether these are
authentic or not of course [__] of
course you do yeah you know you you know
exactly where these things you know came
from how who what office originated them
right who wrote them you know you've got
you've got all this material stored
securely or at least you did if it's
authentic and now how much of this how
much of this mic is like if you know
where it came from
but if you tell everybody where it came
from you're publicly humiliated so you
have to act like you know what I'm
saying like I don't know if that makes
sense or not like saving space yeah no
it does I mean because look this is
anytime you have a leak of intelligence
it's it's embarrassing right I mean it
because it it's embarrassing and and
operationally damaging on on several
different fronts right our allies you
know if this is authentic and these
these these documents are and and if
they are authentic then we've already
told our allies right so when we talk
about well we have this discussion you
know with with our allies over the
weekend well you know
you know this is this is playing out
after the fact so if they are in fact
authentic our allies already know that
they're authentic and so they're already
looking at you know what potential
damage occurred from this
but you're right anytime this happens
it's it's embarrassing right and yet and
yet you're never going to get the
potential for this sort of thing to
happen down to zero right it's not
you're never going to completely re
eliminate the risk of an intelligence
League yeah I'm reading all the stories
by different papers to see what they're
saying New York Times uh Clues left
online might Aid seek investigation
officials say the guardian U.S
intelligence League what do we know
about the top secret documents Moscow
times five things the leaked Pentagon
documents reveal about Russia's Army CNN
leaked Pentagon documents lingered
on social media despite a urgent
National Security concerns CBS News
Pentagon documents League Biden
everybody is pretty much saying the same
thing okay so if everybody is generally
saying the same thing
it kind of minimizes a bit of
gamesmanship right or to you you kind of
maybe sitting there saying well it's Fox
CNN all these guys that don't agree with
each other They're all playing the you
know safe game of saying we don't know
yet what it is but who could it be yeah
it could be these guys it could be those
guys and the allegations everyone makes
their own allegations but nobody know
where it's really coming from you've got
it it's like every decision tree right
no matter what you're talking about
there's not that many branches on it
these are either authentic or they're
not and if they're not it's a
disinformation campaign so who the hell
would have done it well that's another
decision you know Arc it would probably
be the Russians but you have to make
that you know that uh that decision very
quickly in account intelligence
investigation and my point being is that
they already know of course so they're
just you know they're not telling us I
got a question for you Mike yeah so
apparently this these documents were
sitting on Discord for like a month and
then it ended up somehow in a Minecraft
computer game that's something out of
like Fantasyland yeah but when I hear of
leaks and this type of stuff
automatically I go to you know Edward
Snowden Wikileaks Julian Assange you
know this person right here they don't
know who it is if it is a person or if
it's some sort of agency disinformation
campaign is this leaker is he going to
be considered a traitor is there going
to be some sort of whistleblower hero
type thing that gets uh attached to him
what's your opinion on it'll it'll be
all over the Spectrum right I mean there
are people that considered you know
Snowden a hero right and I understand
where they're coming from there are
other people that consider them a
traitor right I get that you know but uh
with with this look it's not the first
time that
um classified documents either ours or
from our allies have ended up in uh as
bizarre as it sounds in sort of The
Gaming Community yeah right and maybe
there's I don't know maybe there's some
connection that we can figure out
between uh people who spend a lot of
time in in the gaming world and you know
individuals who have access to
classified shooter hackers
the screens all day yeah yeah yeah so
and and you know it's again
you can't because of the need to share
information right and there is a
legitimate need to do that you just have
to be careful about how you do it you
don't want to again you don't want to
make such a large playing field that you
have no control over what the hell
you're doing but because of that and
because it's just a human endeavor
you're always going to have the
potential for a problem like this but if
you don't have consequences for it then
you're you're increasing the likelihood
that it could happen again you're not
minimizing the likelihood and the
problem we've always had with with this
sort of thing is there's you know it's a
shifting landscape in terms of from one
Administration to the next how they deal
with this sort of thing it's not it's
certainly not the first time it won't be
the last time but if you don't have
consequences for people who uh who act
out against agreements that they've
already signed right you got to take
that very seriously you sign agreements
right yeah and so you know and that goes
to your grave right you don't you know
it's not you think well I stopped
working or I not get enough hugs work or
boy I don't agree with that policy so
[__] my secrecy agreements yeah you know
that's where you have to you know you
have to have consequences yeah I was
just gonna ask you that because Mike is
up not to cut you off Adam like are at
the base that I was at and miles from
Air Force Base where the funny that's
what the Chinese spy balloon was
hovering at over that of my base it was
the biggest you didn't have anything to
do with that no no no okay I think I
allegedly allegedly but uh the biggest
threat wasn't like a nuclear attack it
was The Insider threat our Insider
threat was the number one threat as
people knowing about the information but
I agree with you 100 you signed the you
sign you're supposed to stay quiet then
all of a sudden you're leaking [__] so
so Mike are you saying that you probably
not probably but is it almost like a
definite they know who the hell did it
whoever leaked it I I think so I mean
just given um you know when you look at
it forensic capabilities now
um you know nothing nothing is
completely deleted
um and and particularly when you're
talking about the power of the the
government you know to pursue an
investigation now whether they're
organized enough to actually do it I
don't know but uh yeah I I think that
they'll they'll sort this one out I
don't think that uh we're not talking
about Lex Luthor here and I think
they'll also sort out and they already
have if this is disinformation so if
these documents are not accurate I think
they'll they would come out relatively
quickly and say that but if there's an
investigation into individuals who have
been responsible for this and they're
authentic it'll probably take a little
bit longer for them not talk the the my
my last question on this is
um you know I feel like all
country spy government spy and this is
you know talking about you know whether
it's the CIA it's MI6 whether it's the
Mossad whether it's the gru in Russia
KGB
um India Pakistan France they all every
country spies and I don't think it's
that concerning that we're spying on
Russia I think that's kind of goes with
the with the story I mean you would hope
we all yeah you hope we are yeah you
know I don't even think it's that big of
a concern we're spying on Ukraine and
zelinski it's like buddy if we're giving
you a [__] couple billion dollars
just believe we're kind of checking in
on you yeah but how big of a concern is
that that they're finding out that we're
spying on South Korea our Ally Israel
our biggest Ally in the Middle East
Mossad how much validity is it there and
how big of a concern is that well
look and also come as a shock but I
Mossad pays attention to what their
allies are doing right so Mossad has an
effort to understand what we're doing
right does that mean they're collecting
Intelligence on us uh yeah and does that
mean the South Koreans to the degree
that they have the resources and and
abilities are they doing the same thing
yes on their allies of course it is
um yeah it's understood right now there
are limits to that right but uh even
with our closest allies there's an
understanding that you
trust but verify right I mean because
every nation acts in its own best
interests right now
you know your your efforts are obviously
far more aggressive when we're talking
about nation states that are not aligned
with us right so no surprise but we
better hope people always say that they
say well we're doing the same damn thing
right we're doing this and
well yeah you better hope we are because
you know as much as you may want to this
is not a world where we're a community
of Nations right and we're all looking
out for each other right and then you
know unicorns all flying out of our
asses and we're all happy and it's just
not it's not the way it works let me let
me ask this question do you think
uh do you think uh
Putin or XI feel like they can get
things done negotiating with Biden do
you think Gian Russia think they can
succeed in negotiations with Biden more
than they would with Trump more than
they would with Obama or somebody new
like a DeSantis
I think what they feel with Biden is
that it's it's a known quantity right
and I think that's I don't know whether
they feel that would be speculating my
part you know what you know how do they
berate them in in regards to who they
can negotiate with better but I do think
that they feel as if Trump is is more of
an unknown quantity uh and they can't
really
you know look and come up with like a
three to five year plan of what so what
did you want to keep it Biden in office
if you know if you know that guy is an
unknown quantity because he's not
predictable
if that is what you assess it assess it
to be you almost want to keep this guy
in office for another six years don't
you well based on look if if all you're
looking at is sort of a decision between
Biden and Trump and you look at Trump's
time in office and you look at Biden's
time in office if I'm a you know a head
of a Nation that's uh at odds with the
U.S I would prefer Biden because I can I
can more accurately predict I think in
my opinion where he's going to go what
his policies are going to be how he's
going to behave right and so yes I mean
I think there's you could you could make
that argument uh Trump was unpredictable
right and that's one of the reasons why
he lost the election people were tired
of the chaos right and but I think with
I mean Biden's been in DC for what 50 50
plus years yeah right you know you know
for me for me I wonder because
anytime a company has a CEO that didn't
want to communicate or I couldn't even
get a sit down with them I didn't I
didn't like that which means I couldn't
get things done I I would much prefer an
[__] that was willing to sit with me
then somebody that was the nicest guy
would never call back never email and
never had time to come and sit down and
visit it's as weird as that sounds yeah
because you know at least the [__]
you know you know what his agenda was
it's his company right against yours
it's his protection but the other guy
would you know was so like aloof and you
had to be very careful with the guys
that were very aloof okay so I wonder if
they sit there and they say you know
because let's put the blame on Russia
let's say Russia's behind this thing
because if Russia is using Israel and
South Korea
it's a form of dividing and conquering
you're pinning Israel against U.S and so
it's very strategic and Brilliant if
that's really what you're doing and to
be so good you also through some of your
internal stuff of Russia to make sure
people don't think you're the one that's
doing it which if you look at it is
absolutely minimal right right it's not
a big deal on their own right oh my God
yeah yeah but that's it's it's again
it's no question about it but but it is
very if let's just say if it is Russia
right then then if they're doing that to
pin Biden against uh uh uh Israel and
South Korea and then maybe they're
saying you know what this Trump guy at
least you know when he was there NATO
was not bothering us he was not a fan of
NATO we're not a fan of NATO you know
yes the trade issues was it is what it
is and we have to deal with that Huawei
we have to deal with that you know I
could never attack Ukraine under him so
do I really want this guy back I can
attack Ukraine under Biden but at the
same time if Trump was here and if I
attack Ukraine under Biden would they
have sent 140 billion dollars to Ukraine
to help would Trump have sent money I
don't know if Trump would have sent
money but maybe Trump would have had a
meeting with me within 24 hours to say
if you don't stop doing this then yeah
so I because to these guys the way I'm
processing it who do you want at the
helm do you want the guy that you can
have in the captain kneecap conversation
and negotiate or do you want the guy
that is you know having worried about
the ice cream he's gonna have and you
don't really know if you can have a real
conversation that's my biggest thing who
do you want as an enemy sometimes I want
the leader of the enemy to be somebody I
can talk to no matter how much I may not
like the guy and how much we disagree
yeah yeah I I that's it's a an odd thing
here in the US I think maybe it's
elsewhere but this idea that you have to
like the person in charge right I don't
you know I didn't like Trump I don't
like Trump necessarily I think he's just
too chaotic and I think he's you know
he's all over the map I liked the
policies right I liked the policies
better uh I don't need to like the
person necessarily I'm more interested
in what are they doing you know as as a
leader so but with you know Putin I I'm
sure you know Putin looked at Ed Biden
and he remembered it was Obama Biden
when they you know walked into Crimea
and there was no response right they
took Crimea and and during that
Administration and you know there was no
pushback really to speak of and so they
probably factor that into their
calculation over Ukraine I I'm sure
Putin was surprised at the at the my
monetary response sort of the way the
Allies came together and said because I
I figure that calculation was probably
different they probably thought the U.S
will not get quite so involved they will
not make quite the effort with NATO but
um I I you know to that degree his
intelligence was was clearly off but um
yeah I I agree with you I think you know
if I'm
if I'm looking at this and I certainly
if I'm G if I'm G and I think that I'm
close to the top of the of the of the
ladder here
um I would much rather have somebody
like President Biden in place because
again I can look at him and I think I
can I can map out and predict based on
50 plus years where he's going if that's
the case I won't do this because this
hurts that's the only thing so if I'm
sitting here thinking about you're doing
this I wouldn't do this because you're
hurting the existing guy because you're
giving more ammunition to the opposing
side I I would I would let it roll
rather than doing this to say hey
because do you remember when Trump had
to keep firing people in Sienna CNN and
MSNBC would constantly say there's a uh
uh Source within Trump Administration
what a terrible thing to do to a guy to
confuse a crap at him like think about
when they say there's a player within
the New England Patriots organizations
that's leaking information to us at ESPN
that there's a major fight and have
fallen out between Tom Brady and Bill
like those types of things and your
Brady and Belichick you're like hey guys
stop it we're good we don't have it but
then in the back your mind you're like
who's talking [__] is it that guy that I
pinched is it that guy that I didn't let
through this is it that guy that I
didn't invite to the part is it that guy
that wants to be traded what is it
regardless of how much bulletproof
strong mentally tough you are they get a
little bit of your brain and you start
thinking so regardless no matter how
bulletproof this Administration may be
they're going to say who at the Pentagon
wants Republican Trump to be there
that's not on our side we got to fire
this person who is that person it's a
general this it's a general is it this
person's death this this this really
throws a wrench in the game yeah that's
all I'm saying so I don't know yeah yeah
I mean again it's it's speculation at
this point obviously you know to say
that you know it could it be uh a uh
covert action campaign by the Russians
but I'm saying that when you do
something like this when you're
investigating somebody this you have to
keep all the options on the table until
you approve otherwise and you know
that's it's and again and I I would
argue that they they already know if
they don't already know what's going on
with this then that is really
disappointing yeah if if you're doing it
at the KGB level of Putin trust me
Putin's got like a board of I would
assume he's got a board of everybody who
to poke to piss off with who and create
a proxy here to unify here so we can
become the good guy and call these guys
and do a favor for that guy so he can
connect us with this guy and get in
front of I mean I'm assuming that's how
these rooms these conversations are
going to be had so yeah and it's
election time you got eight more months
left nine more months left before we
decide who the Republican candidate's
gonna be so the Santa's Trump you know
who do you want to be the head if you
are really meddling in elections I would
be really more thought out of who I'd
want to eliminate to create the enemy
against yeah I don't know so let me just
I want to ask one I want to go into
another story you make your point and
I'm gonna go I want to go full
conspiracy mode right now
in the last month
I'm going into Vinnie Taylor
last month the Chinese spy balloons
a couple weeks after that Putin uh hosts
she
in Moscow those two are having
conversations Putin's having a love
affair with she waving by like a school
girl love you what kind of conversations
do you think those two guys are having
behind closed doors about America how
are we going to make America we click on
okay now they're they're they're
completely together at this point
everything that's happening Ukraine has
basically you know thrown Putin right
into xi's arms he basically said he was
kind of jealous of the success China has
had over the last few decades and wishes
that type of success for Russia what
kind of conversations are happening
behind closed doors and how much
plotting against America is uh in those
conversations yeah well look I mean the
dynamic there is definitely that that
China's in the driver's seat you know
Putin's in sort of the supplicant
position here
um and and that relationship
uh only goes so far even though they
said there's no limits to our friendship
or [__] of course they are you know
as soon as she decides it's not in their
best interests you know to to push this
Dynamic but you know geez working to try
to position China as uh The Peacemaker
around the globe right he's trying to
increase sort of his diplomatic standing
as it were I guess and and at the same
time he's you know he's rattling his
saber over there at Taiwan that's a
delicate balance between those two
things uh but with yeah I mean Putin
absolutely needs China on side he's got
almost nothing else right the Iranians
are selling them drones and you know
he's you know at Belarus God I got
Belarus on my side uh but ultimately you
know what's China gaining gaining cheap
energy right they're watching as both
Russia and America you know uh empty
their warehouses of military hardware
yep so there's a lot you know to be
gained from China's perspective and all
of this and Russia is in a position
where it needs to you know it needs to
kind of do this right and speaking of
perspective by the way you know you just
brought up to Taiwan thing so it's the
same it's very similar it's analogous to
exactly what's happening so Russia
invades Ukraine what was the response
from America what was the response from
the rest of the world the response from
the EU okay now China invades Taiwan
what's the response going to be we've
seen this play out almost like War Games
those types of conversations must be
taking place do you think any of this
Beyond I want to be completely honest I
know you said Trump chaotic and I I
understand what the chaos came from
because as he came in fake Russia all
that I'd be pissed off too if I was him
I'd have a huge huge chip on my shoulder
I'd be upset with the meat and
everything too do you think all our
economy recession inflation our dollars
going by by militarily where people are
Afghanistan withdrawal and all that do
you think that the majority of this is
happening under Trump honestly do you
think this is still the way that we are
right now no no because I think the
policies would have been different look
I mean you know you you covet came along
and kind of [__] things up obviously
obviously yeah but so that that was an
outlier uh but I I do think that if a
the economy I mean look the first thing
that that Biden did and he campaigned on
it you know was shutting down the energy
sector right and you know one of the the
the the really uh strong elements of the
Trump economy was oil and gas right and
and National Security and energy
Independence are completely linked you
can't separate the two so no I think
there's I think there's some significant
differences that could have occurred do
I think that Trump's gonna you know win
in 2024 I don't see how he gets to that
number because I don't think the people
who who didn't vote for him the second
time around those people who were tired
of the chaos so the people said I gotta
have enough Biden won because he wasn't
Trump he didn't win because he's a great
leader right he lost two times before he
simply won because he wasn't Trump but
are those people who didn't vote for
Trump that time are they suddenly going
to look around and go yeah I want some
more of that Trump yeah I don't see how
he gets to that number you know it's
crazy you say that so we're at the UFC
fight this weekend in Miami which by the
way it broke when Dana White came out he
talked about how the last time they were
in Miami I think they did 436 at the
door this time they did 11.9 million
beating Madison Square Gardens record of
11.5 million okay and he says Miami is
what La was 10 years ago and he's
selling Miami so we're definitely going
to come back a year from us the video of
him talking but you know anyways we
don't need to play it but one of the
things that happened is while you're
there suddenly the crowd starts losing
their mind
feeling you don't hear
everybody taking out their phones and
then all of a sudden eruption there was
nothing because this guy named Donald
Trump walked in 21
000 phones were lifted
everybody's got their cameras on shaking
hands people are trying to spot is that
Mel Gibson that just shook his hand yeah
that's Mike Tyson sitting next to him of
course Dana White and you know he always
speaks very highly even because of how
Trump helped him out at the beginning
and you know mazvidal gives a speech the
literally the place is going crazy we're
right back there by the way in that
video so the place is going absolutely
Bonkers right mozvidel then starts
fighting Burns in the middle of the
fight
camera goes on him Trump was watching a
fight nobody cares anymore everybody so
so the department comes now here's
here's what the the conversation becomes
either a hundred percent of UFC viewers
are Republicans
or this guy has an energy about himself
when he walks and that he's able to
convert and
magnetic energy I even looked at Adam
for a second and Adam was in tears
Adam do you know what that Adam was can
you tell the truth you know what Adam
said by the way if you want me to tell
the truth I'll tell the truth tell the
truth yeah Adam says I'm not gonna lie
to you you know how I feel about Trump I
just went from here to here
very weird feeling right it was actually
cool [__] but you know but you know what
you know it was it was great but but
here here's the part as well the one
thing about politics we had uh uh I said
Ari Fleischer is that George Washington
sorry was here and I said why get into
the game of politics like why why get
into this like he says are you kidding
me and he says unlike Sports where
there's a Leader's bulletin and you know
if that guy scored a touchdown or did
this or did
politics there is no Leader's bulletin
is who can sell their argument and their
ideas better wow it's the greatest
competition and he sold it in a way that
I bet a few thousand kids that watch it
20 year old guys are watching saying I
want to get into politics he sold the
industry so well wow so don't do it kids
don't do it so the point is none of us
have a clue what the hell we're talking
about when it comes down to who's going
to win who's not you know the reality of
what happened with you but Biden won
because they just didn't want Trump
right you know all those vote okay fine
no problem well now you got what you
wanted how happy are you now okay when
you have a what Sarah is that her name
girl name girl's name is Sarah Foster is
that the actress's name did you hear
what what happened in San Francisco with
the soul uh uh the cast guys no no no
what's her daughter's name you were
going to make your point before I played
this for you well I was gonna say you
know you get what you get I mean look
Chicago is a perfect example of that
right they got rid of Lori Lightfoot and
what did they bring in someone harder to
laugh yeah right so I don't know how do
you explain that one yeah if you can go
on Twitter Rob if you can go on Twitter
so just recently this this lady I want
everybody to go send a tweet at this
lady because apparently she just got off
of Twitter just go to my account right
there go right there that's exactly the
one I want you to do so before you play
the video pause it before you play the
video here's a lady okay zoom in a
little bit so they can see it her name
is Hillary Ronan just so you know what
she does she sits on the board I think
it's District nine if you can go on
Google and Google her who she is Hillary
Ronan uh two L's Hillary Ronan n-e-n
Hillary Ronin n e n there you go Hillary
Ronan zoom in so we can see who she is
and I watch this is such an interesting
thing Hillary Ronin is an American
politician attorney serving as a member
of the San Francisco boards yeah there
you go District nine which includes the
neighborhoods of Mission District Vernal
Heights and Portola okay and if you go a
little lower so we know who she is
Democratic party uh she went to Berkeley
University California University in San
Francisco okay great now go back to the
tweet so this lady here in 2000 and let
me even send you the Tweet because a lot
of people haven't seen the tweet this is
a tweet she sends out I don't know if I
send it to you Rob if you have it please
show the tweet I think I send that to
you as well it's this one right here if
you can just pull up the Tweet because a
lot of times you see an image of a tweet
and then the person goes back and
deletes it you can't find it well
luckily I found the tweet and she's left
it up so just kind of pull it up great
if you send it to yourself by Hillary
Ronan the date of her tweet is
let me see what the date is she sent us
in 2020 uh to be exact on a date August
16 2020 do you have it I text it to you
rob yeah I texted to you should have the
text that I sent you uh well I just I
just put a thumbs up on it Rob if you
can just pull that up just put do copy
paste she's still in San Francisco you
got to see this thing here you got to
see this thing here what she says uh uh
Rob if you're
let's see if you got it or not because
she's still past she's still in you have
to see what this woman says and she's
still in charge so in 2020 this is her
tweet I want to make it clear that I
strongly I believe strongly in defunding
the police and reducing the number of
officers on our Force for decades we've
had an imbalance in our City's budget
with hundreds of millions of dollars
going to San Francisco PD to have them
do work they are not qualified to do
okay look at the date okay August 16
2020. okay bookmark that by the way they
lowered a budget by 120 million dollars
the mayor during that time okay so now
go back to the tweet and watch her video
of what she says go to the video of what
she says you just had to tweet out here
we can play the clip this is watch this
we've been begging for more footbeats
and for more officers
in the Mission District two weeks ago
again this department to give the
mission what it deserves in terms of
police presence
all year long and I have been told time
and time and time and time again there
are no officers that we can send to
Mission it hurts and I feel betrayed oh
no Hillary by the department I feel
betrayed by the mayor I feel betrayed by
the priorities of this city it is not
this Board of Supervisors priorities we
want our residents safe her name's
Hillary her name is Hillary
shots getting assaulted getting killed
because in the mission chief
it's not theft and the mission people
are getting shot and killed and the
mission people are getting beat up and
the mission people are dying no no [__]
Sherlock
go on Twitter and look at her last tweet
go go just go to her account right there
and look at her last tweet okay zoom in
her last 323 at peace out Twitter time
is precious we'll be using time I spend
on this forum having direct productive
conversations with the people of San
Francisco good luck to you lady yeah
this is the part where yeah you know you
know as sad as it is because a guy who
created a great company that's created
thousands of jobs who moved to Miami
because he didn't feel safe in the
middle of the night gets stabbed a week
after this a week and a half after
whatever two weeks after this comment
she makes and she's the same person so
now why don't you come out and apologize
about your original uh policies never
about the fact that you felt about
defunding the police now you want to
talk about I feel that they're not
wanting to protect the city Sarah Foster
is an actress yeah I love that you found
anybody who any anybody who makes it on
Vanity Fair you're like left of left
you're part of the camp 100 you're
qualified she slams San Francisco for
being a [__] weird so go go to the
bottom to read the entire quote of what
she said right there I have no words
right there at the bottom go a little
lower little I have no words San
Francisco is a complete [__] I'm a
registered Democrat and feel confident
saying liberal politicians are ruining
cities disgusting my heart breaks for
this family okay and this is the
daughter of David Foster by the way 16
time Grammy winner 16 time yeah you know
it's crazy you know you started us off
with UFC and all that funny story so you
know the guy freaking stole my keys that
were running around Vinnie and I run
around the whole time the whole time we
go to the uh guest services and the one
guy in front of us at Guest Services
Vinnie remember this he goes oh [__]
what's up man
Jersey huge fan I'm like what's up buddy
he goes I'm a cop in Jersey yeah I just
came down here with my girl to have a
great time UFC boom Oh tell Pat I said
what's up I said what's up he goes I
gotta tell you you know how they say
talk about defund the police let me tell
you something was he talking about New
Jersey police
said he said before coven
he said they would get between 80 000
and a hundred thousand applicants
to join the police force he goes you
know what it is now in a year
1500. yep did he not say those numbers
he did this is his story I said what I
got that it's the same story ridiculous
increase a decrease and I said so how
are you gonna find uh police officers
now he goes we're just gonna have to
lower standards no you just got to move
to Florida come on down here we like
cops his name is his name is Nick Davis
I'm pretty sure he told us a number and
Adam Adam was like whoa the hell with my
keys what from a hundred some thousand
to 1500 it's it's am I just so here's my
question for everybody is is people's
hate for Trump more important than going
back to not having the economy like this
the the way that everything is where
where are these voters at you so you're
just happy because the mean attitude guy
is not in but you know what as long as
my feelings aren't hurt I don't give a
[__] about the country I don't give a
[__] about uh the War I don't give a
[__] about the economy like where where
the hell is your what are you talking
about yell at me all [__] day be
whatever as long as I'm safe and the
economy is good and everything's all
right I'm happy that's me yeah you know
what I think never underestimate the
Republicans ability to like shoot
themselves in the foot right or [__] up
their chances to win I mean I I would
argue that the abortion argument is
another example of that right I mean
what the what the hell right yeah
McConnell yeah they [__] up the
midterm election you know
um and it's gonna happen again right I
have a feeling that there's you know
again I hate to say it because I would
like to see a change in administration
right 330 million plus people in this
country and we're heading towards
another you know election season where
it's probably going to be Biden to Trump
again I I I suspect right it's the
favorite and that's that's incredible to
me but I I I you know I'm I'm a fan of
the policies right you know we gotta we
gotta clear out the regulations we got
to get the economy moving uh we've got
to focus be more uh strategic with uh
with China and uh I just don't uh
I I just don't see how the numbers get
there for for Trump uh unless there's
just you know a more significant crisis
yeah right because I think those voters
who may have said who may have said okay
I didn't vote from the last time but
this you know current administration's
not not cutting it I'm going to go for
uh the Republicans but I think those
people will probably be turning up based
on the abortion issue and I think
they're going to look at that I think a
lot of those Suburban women and the
others who were tired of the Trump chaos
who didn't vote for him this last time
they probably maybe they could have
shifted back to the Republican you know
and vote for for him but I think that
abortion issue is going to shut that
possibility down so I'm not particularly
optimistic we could end up with Biden
Harris again and then we're going to end
up with Harris what how different is
that position of what happened and what
the sentences position is with that
because is the Santa's position on Roe v
Wade different than what happened right
before midterms yeah I don't think I
don't think desantises is I mean I know
there's there's been a lot of talk about
the Santa's being the guy you know
possibly that could you know take this
but I I don't I don't think so I just
don't I think outside of I don't think
he's going to Care he could carry the
the nation I don't know I I think that
you're looking at a split in the numbers
uh they're going to be you know sitting
in their Foxhole shooting at each other
during the primary and that's going to
damage both of them and I just uh just
said here's what Newsome agrees with You
Gavin Newsom predicts what will happen
if we're on the census takes on Trump
this is a Newsweek story Rob while I'm
doing this find what uh Trump just put
out in truth social about Ron DeSantis
it's the nicest message you said so far
by the way California governor gavinism
predicts that if uh DeSantis challenges
Trump for 2024 Republican Presidential
nomination
the centers will be defeated by Trump
Newsom said on MSNBC inside with jensaki
is going to get rolled by Trump Trump's
just going to roll him Newsom criticized
the scientists for attacking Manhattan
district attorney Alvin Braggs who
charged Trump with 34 counts of
falsifying business documents Newsome
centers looked weak for doing so and
advised the centers against challenging
Trump for the GOP nomination he
suggested the sentence wait a few years
and actually do some of the hard work
which actually includes governing not
just identity and culture War so Mike
are you the kind of guy that likes this
Newsome guy
yeah yeah yeah
Newsome is uh when he talks about the
Santa should just focus on government
good god
um I'm I'm in and out of Los Angeles and
and to be fair San Francisco on a
regular basis and uh two fantastic
cities that are just being driven into
the ground and you know that's all under
Newsome's watch like the guy he's got a
you know a great head of hair
um you know God bless him but uh I'm
sure he positions himself where he's
imagining himself to be the guy right he
nobody was probably happy about Buddhist
judge you know taking a lot of you know
shots during uh the past year than
Newsom because I think he really feels
like he's the replacement candidate 100
and you know he's I'm sure he's excited
about the fact that
you know I I don't know what do I know
about about uh politics other than you
have to look at results right and
Newsome doesn't have the results right
so I I don't understand but it doesn't
matter anymore it's all about
performative art right it's it's theater
and people you you talk about how the
the San Francisco uh woman there you
know can how can she say one thing and
then talk out of the other side of her
mouth right sure thereafter it's because
nobody gives a [__] anymore right nobody
fact checks nobody and you know so this
that's a you know but again
you know you get I guess to your point
you get what you get you know you vote
for you know you vote for how do they
end up with Brandon Johnson in Chicago
how does that work have you heard what
this guy says he's nuts yeah have you
listen to some of the stuff this guy is
I mean it's worse it's it but it's a
Soros guy yeah but it's one of Sorrows
guys and you saw who visited the White
House 12 or 14 times last uh
his boy which by the way a lot of people
think well when Soros is no longer here
because he's 90 some years old listen
his son is as radical if not apparently
more radical than him he's meeting with
the chief of staff and he's had all
these other meetings and by the way can
you pull up what actually I sent you
about what uh Trump said about uh uh uh
DeSantis I just sent it to the link
there you go if you can pull that up
with the hill oh yeah here's what he
just said zoom in a little bit Trump
discourages the Santa says candidacy
with only her Republican party okay a
different approach here's what he says
Rhonda Santos is a young man who is not
doing well against me the polls to put
it in mild I believe that if he decides
to run for president which will only
hurt and somewhat divide a Republican
party he will lose the cherished and
massive Mega vote he's already saying it
right up front and never be able to
successfully run for office again I
don't know about that if he remains
Governor which is what Florida voters
assumed it will be a whole different
story just saying but again who knows
some people read into this and they said
the fact that he's hinting at if you
don't run I'll have you as my VP some
are saying that'll never happen but uh
what do you think about what he just
said here about the scientists
it's one of the nicer things he said in
the last few months is not calling a
meatball Ron or Ron the sanctimonious or
you know uh peddling stories about him
hanging out with underage women so
that's that's good for him
um which
there's actually some truth you know to
use some truth social in it that that he
might uh lose the massive cherished Maga
vote
um one of the things I actually wanted
to bring about to sandus that you just
brought about this is some one of the
things because I've been an advocate of
saying I would vote for DeSantis have
you heard about the fact that because
you brought up abortions and how like
that's gonna potentially shoot uh
Republicans shoot themselves in the foot
especially to Suburban women or just
women across the country you know it's
supposed to be a red wave in the
midterms it ended up being like a red
like Drop in the bucket yeah
um Florida backed by DeSantis is trying
to pass a six week abortion bill
six weeks yeah have you heard about this
pull this up and apparently it was
approved now listen you can debate the
abortion all you want but uh six weeks
some women you know don't even know
they're pregnant within a month the
first month and I think the stats show
um
43 of pregnancies hap of abortions
happen within six weeks 36 percent
happen between seven and nine weeks 13
between 10 and 13 weeks so I think a lot
of people have sort of used like the
12-week number as sort of a
you know comfortable number that you can
wrap your head around but six weeks so
if
back to your point about the scientists
if that's your message that you're going
to be more of a moderate and you know
kind of not play to the mega Wing but
also uh get some of the disaffected
Liberals and Independence on your side a
six week abortion bill you think that's
going to get women to vote for you yeah
no I know Homie don't play that well and
this this is why it's it's it's always
been one of those issues right it's like
you're talking about you know reformed
entitlements right I mean every time the
Republican Party Wades into the abortion
issue you know it I I don't get how do
they how do they not look at this and go
okay you know what we got to sit down
and come up with nobody lives in the
[__] Center anymore so nobody you
don't have anybody in Washington saying
let's all sit down as reasonable people
and come up with something right that
that makes sense that both sides can
live with you have one Centrist you have
Joe manchin yeah yeah basically that's
it yeah but I don't think I don't know
that you know look if the Santos was to
Republican nominee yeah I'd vote for him
right but
I think Trump's correct in the sense
that
you know all he's got to do is kind of
you know start that attack plan and you
know his voting base is not going to
suddenly Embrace Ron DeSantis right so
there's a I think there's a real problem
coming down the pike for the Republican
party that that you know typically
they'll just ignore for a while uh and
then you know it'll be sort of all hands
on deck and panic you know leading up to
the election and but if you're a
DeSantis you don't know what's going to
happen four or five years from now you
can't predict you know Florida might
have a hurricane it might be an absolute
mess here you never know what kind of
six-week abortion Bill all of a sudden
approval ratings go down right now his
stock is as high as ever you have to
seize the moment Carpe Diem oh yeah
because I don't think yeah you just
nailed it like think about it if Trump
runs this one and Ron doesn't nobody's
he's going to be literally could be
irrelevant it could be people just like
okay just stay in Florida like whatever
but just it's crazy though that that's
all the Democratic party has to offer
yes unless if
Trump
does back him up 100 to run afterwards
because think about it this way say
Trump runs four years okay okay and the
sentence goes behind them I want you to
think about this uh here real quick say
DeSantis says all right I'll get
involved a little bit just to get a
little bit of experience and I'll run
and apparently he can't run until July
because he has to get his governorship
job in place before he announces that
he's running some date like I think it's
July but I think it's July so he goes in
and they duke it out for five months
whatever the time six months five months
and then within two three months okay
guess what game it's yours perfect
they talk to each other just like Ted
Cruz lined up and Ted Cruz like let's go
let's roll Trump can flip real quick if
you're gonna get his back he'll flip
right so DeSantis comes and backs them
up and they run now watch during Trump's
second term if the sentence got his back
100 percent
guess what Trump's going to do for
DeSantis Trump's going to be his number
one flag carrier and help him become
president and then DeSantis can have 12
years eight years which means it'll be
Trump to say in this 12 years now that
doesn't mean a DeSantis Camp listen to
this they're saying oh you have no clue
what the hell you're talking about maybe
you're right maybe we don't we're just
talking guys we're not in your world and
you know and you're right about the fact
that this guy was the number one
governor in what he did above and beyond
everybody else we're in Florida because
of this guy you're from LA and New York
I'm from L.A and I lived in Texas for
five years and I like the governor in
Texas he does a great job yeah but we
moved here because it gave the balance
of Florida and Texas together I love the
beach in Idaho but I love it in Florida
so favorite beaches this is the whole
Beach life that's right this is the
difference between this now if you find
this clip with Biden being asked about
running for reelection I don't know if
you saw out there if you just go if you
have that the Easter egg hunt yeah what
is he saying Pat what does he saying
while he's looking for it I'll just read
it to you on what happened with this so
uh I'm planning on running for by the
way you have to really understand what
he's saying matter of fact I dare you to
fully understand what he's saying go out
and play the clay watch this here that's
the doctor this is a fantastic event
this is my favorite of the year I was
just wondering uh Mr President uh will
you be uh taking part in the Easter egg
rolls uh after planning on after 2025. I
plan on at least three or four more
Easter egg rolls at least three or four
more maybe five maybe five maybe six
what the hell are you are you saying
that uh that you would be uh taking part
in uh our upcoming election in 2014.
I'll either be rolling an egg or you
know being the the you know the guy
who's pushed him out come on
I plan on running now but we're not
prepared to announce it yet all right
you ain't black I was waiting for that
to come out because he loves oh that's
the announcement it's not the official
announcement he just said it without
saying it with an egg coming out
whatever the hell that yeah how's he
pushing that again
[Music]
I just wish we had one honestly
if he's maybe he identifies as a chicken
there's nothing wrong with that there's
nothing wrong with that yeah I'm not I'm
not I just wish one time one person
interviewing just stops and goes like
this hey uh I'm sorry Mr President what
the hell are you talking about say what
buddy yeah yeah exactly nobody ever
checks him Trump was always yelled at by
Jim Acosta and everybody not one but he
didn't talk like this before I've heard
him give speech it's getting worse no
I've heard him give speeches where
you're kind of like okay okay good you
know he's he's got some stuff that's
solid he he didn't talk like this this
is recent and Pat notis but but it's
gonna be he's gonna be 82 right by the
next election if he gets realized he'll
be 86 years old
it has to be a concern of course it is
if you can push an egg out at 86. you
gotta respect it you should be president
man uh yeah it's uh he's doing look he
he successfully ran a campaign from his
basement for the most part of course and
you know again the Democrat threats see
you know I love them hate them right
they they tend to do messaging and
campaigns and communication well because
they stick to it right they they don't
tend to Splinter and so I think his
strategists are basically saying look
why jump in the fight right now hey take
take all the time you want right you
don't you're in the the White House
already you don't need to announce yet
and he could push us off and while he's
doing that he's kind of freezing out the
other options like Newsom and these
others right so right so we've got
you know we've got a really interesting
situation here where I think both sides
are kind of getting locked in to before
we even get to the uh the primary but
shit's about to get it but it's gonna
get so dirty and I think this next one's
going to be nasty I think it's gonna be
nasty anyways we got to get to the end
of the podcast so Nathaniel Rodriguez
gave 100 Super Chat good conversation
Andrew Huff uh there's a there's not a
regime that the U.S via the CIA and the
state department have wanted to cool and
topple bricks and the recent peace deals
between countries led by China and
Russia plus Trump as president why they
don't want him in 2024. I guess we'll
find out to see what's going to happen
yeah uh Mike what are you working on
right now so people can follow you what
what are you working on uh outside of
your new uh office you're building in
San Francisco but outside
building my secret lair in the Mission
District
um because the representation seems
solid uh by the way this thing goes so
fast great it's it's such a great show I
mean it just moves so damn fast
um that I'm surprised that we're at the
end of it you're a fan favorite by the
way oh you're a fan favorite not only do
we love you everybody loves you you're a
fan favorite clearly 10K live right yeah
your your viewers are clearly terrible
judges and entertainment value but
um you know what I uh Hey for uh for all
your information and security needs it's
Portman Square group I gotta say that
because why not that's a that's a great
one and then yeah I uh thank you very
much Rob I uh pushed out an audiobook uh
a couple months ago called company rules
uh it's a very easy listen
um they asked me to do an audio book
because I didn't know enough big words
to do a whole book and I narrated myself
so it's very soon that voice I could go
to sleep
everything I know about business I
learned from the CIA wow yeah and it's
got uh it's got just some principles I
took away look I I what I what happened
was I I got out of the agency and
everybody in my old colleagues who were
fantastic I loved my time in but they
were all like what the hell are you
going to do now you have no how are you
gonna what yeah you sit home and I had
to leave because I was raising a
daughter uh as a single dad and I was
like okay you know I got to do something
that keeps me close to home someone and
but all all my guys were like yeah I
don't know what the hell you're gonna be
doing because your your skill said it's
not going to transfer to the private
sector and and what I found was after
starting a business
um was that there were certain things
that I'd learned from the agency that
actually transferred very well to the
private sector right these were my rules
it's not like the agency hands you a
book that says here's the company rules
when you first sign on these were just
the things I took away and hopefully
people enjoy it they take some bit away
and they it helps them and not just in
business but in private life I love it
well Rob let's make sure we put the link
all over the place chat and description
folks go order Mike Baker's book and I'm
sure Mike will be doing this again in
the next I hope so 17 months going into
the election man that's gonna be well
anyways thanks for coming out thank you
have a good one we'll do it again on
Thursday take care everybody bye-bye